[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host today joined
by dr john dolone best-selling author
two phds host of the dr john deloney
show and we're excited to take your call
about life money mental health
boundaries relationships whatever you're
thinking about ruminating in your brain
we're here for you the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five mason kicks us off in lubbock texas
john d'alone is a big fan of that place
mason welcome to the show
good afternoon thanks for taking my call
guys
absolutely how can we help
so i just have wanted some advice my
wife and i are potentially about to
start the process of
building a new home
um we haven't you know applied for
the loan or anything just yet i wanted
to make sure that we had enough cash
saved up
uh just for that process
okay what's your income
so our income is uh
about 1 to 110.
cool a year you all work
um i work with a family business we do
dirt work and trucking and then she is
uh actually uh direct sales network
marketing
why do i want to build instead of buying
um
an existing home
so we actually have a a really good
friend that is a home builder he built
our last our current home
we moved into it um
it will be coming up two years in march
so we get a pretty decent deal and we
hit that market pretty
with good timing that we built up a good
amount of equity in this current home
and so
this has land and we're moving to a
little bit of land as well and this home
just has the floor plan and everything
that we actually get to choose so
um
so you built a home but you didn't get
to choose how it was built
the first time correct so he's a home
builder and he was building uh back
homes okay and um we
the foundation and everything was poured
and we decided to buy that one and uh so
we didn't really get to choose the floor
plan but we got the shows you know
choose a few things okay what's the
current one worth if you sold it today
so we recently got our first you know
tax appraisal and it was valued at 550
000.
what'd you pay for it
370. you know that and you may not know
the lubbock tax appraisals i've had many
of them are
garbage nowhere reflective of the market
value up or down have you talked to a
real estate agent to figure out what
your home would actually sell for based
on comps in the area
we haven't talked to an agent yet um
we
just basically we know
one couple that just sold for about 5
20.
so
i know that's
possibly in the range
but that's kind of where we're trying to
play it a little bit safer not expect
that much but then make our decision as
far as when to actually start the
process how much is this new house
you're going to build
the construction budget that our our
builder thinks will be about 500.
okay and we're going to stay well below
that
but what's what's the all-in cost
you gave me construction budget that's
all in
that would be the always yeah
and what would you net let's say you
sold the home for 520 today what would
you net
if we sold for 520 we would net about
245
okay so you'd be able to put about are
you gonna put all of that as a down
payment
yes that's gonna be all rolled into
the
new loan okay
so what's your question today you're
asking if you should start
yes so
what's holding you back
we are expecting a baby in january oh
congrats that's our first one uh thank
you
and that's kind of just been uh
a little doubt that i've had on my mind
not doubt necessarily but i just want to
make sure that we have plenty saved up
for that and then you know the closing
costs to get the new loan started
and then
i just want to do it the smart way so
what's the urgency to build this new
home because you said you were in this
current one for less than two years
yes
uh so that was kind of our original plan
going into it since we got such a good
deal
on the first one we were just going to
do that build two years sell and you
know
avoid the capital gains and kind of just
make a little income on that
as far as build up equity in the home
and
that's really there's really no urgency
i guess um so that's why i'm fine with
waiting until
you know even the spring but
one other thing is we do own
the lot that the next one will go on um
so the down payment
that will be
you know put towards the down payment so
it won't be a lot of cash up front
um
this sounds like less of a money issue
let me let me do this let me give you
permission
you and your wife had a plan to to do
the two-year and flip thing and if you
do that every few years and when your
seventh house or whatever it's free or
whatever that thing is y'all had that
plan
and then she's like took you out to and
like guess what we're having a baby and
you're like yay and then you remembered
what building a house did to your
marriage and you're like oh this sounds
great what if we threw that we did that
again and we added a new baby to the mix
this would be a blast and so i want you
to feel permission
to circle back and say hey we have a
custom-built home that came to us with
150 plus thousand dollars in equity that
our friend someone we trust built us on
land in a nice community blob all this
stuff
it's okay if we sit still for a minute
it's okay
george you're better than the math the
math is fine yeah yeah financially this
is a fine decision i'm just questioning
the the motive behind it
i don't hear you want to do this you
usually use let me put it so usually
people call me and george with this
question
they're trying to do mathematical
gymnastics to make this thing
able to happen you say on the opposite
you're like i feel like you're asking us
please tell me no please let me know so
we can just stay put
right
yeah
with our last build it was
we actually sold our home and then we
were kind of out of a house for you know
about three weeks and
i think there's a little
a little stress that's still around and
i just want to make sure that everything
is smooth and maybe this is not i have
never
george you may have i have not met a
single person across the united states
of america in the last 36 months who has
built a home who has said the words it
was super smooth
um this date hit here all the budgets
were were right on all the the materials
showed up on the day they were supposed
to and we sold our house and moved to
the next one just like we planned i
haven't heard nothing a single person
has said that we built our town home
three years ago and it was a second
full-time job i was staying on top of
the contractors they put the towel bar
in the wrong place the paint color's
wrong the granite's wrong i mean i've
our pet's heads were falling off it was
a nightmare and so it's not for the
faint of heart i'm gonna go ahead and
wait let's have this baby let's make
sure mom and baby are home safe
then let's figure out where we're at
with this new home purchase but there's
no urgency here i'm not gonna add any
more stress to this when you're having
your first baby you got a lot going on
you just got into this house enjoy it a
little bit longer you'll be okay and
financially you're in great shape so i'm
not worried about that part but hey keep
saving up what if you could put 60 70
down and pay off the mortgage in a year
or two that would be incredible i'm down
with that plan
more of your calls coming up triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help
go to their site churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsey personality george campbell host
of the fine print and the entree
leadership podcast joined today by dr
john dolone host of the aptly named i
might say the dr john deloney show john
i saw you doing the show earlier today
this morning how'd it go
um
i heard some laughter from the caller so
you guys sounded like you were having a
good time there's a couple of calls that
were or what it called it's pretty dark
today i think that meant the second one
we had to laugh or
the show was going to get off the rails
you do bring a beautiful um levity to
some hard really hard situations yeah we
get a taste of that here on the show but
your show it's even darker yeah it's
pretty it can be pretty tough sometimes
yeah well there's a lot always light at
the end of the tunnel well thank you for
going first i'm glad it's you and not me
well we're here to take your calls about
money life relationships
never mind i'll say it
george joking i'm not gonna do that wow
look at that john using his filter
james mark that down this is a historic
day
triple eight eight two five five two two
five xavier joins us up next in orlando
xavier welcome to the show
thank you again thank you thank you for
taking my call absolutely how can john
and i help
so i'm going today because i'm having a
debate here uh i'm in college i'm going
back to college after five years uh i
moved a quick quick background i came
from puerto rico in 2017 i was studying
electrical engineering down there but i
stopped it when i moved
and now i'm trying to get back because i
only have 44 credits to go to finish my
electric engineering degree and i'm just
having a hard time in between paying
down debt or cash in cash inflow uh my
college
what kind of debt do you have
uh having a
thousand dollars of debt uh i have sold
some student loans sixty three thousand
dollars from where i was back in puerto
rico i have uh thirteen thousand dollars
in uh personal loans i have eleven
thousand and nine hundred dollars in
credit card debt
uh i'm gonna i have a current balance in
college of uh seventeen hundred dollars
and some other three hundred and ninety
dollars you know all like bill that i
have wow do you have a car payment
nope i yes
have i have two paid four cars two and
that's that's all my depth yes sir what
do you need two cars for
uh well i have my my own personal car to
uh to for work and my wife has a paid
for car too oh okay your wife that makes
more sense i just thought you got
married yeah yeah oh okay cool what's
your household income
uh between both of us uh we make 85k
a year i'm an electrician and she uh she
works for an insurance health insurance
company
okay cool
well as far as your question you're
wondering when
you know should i focus on paying off
the debt i want you to cash flow college
i don't want you to go a penny more into
debt and so whatever it takes to do that
that's the plan if that means
pausing on going back to college to
finish this electrical engineering
degree i'm okay with that because that's
going to be real stressful trying to
cash flow while trying to keep up with
all these payments on this side
okay
so you already are working in your field
you're as an electrician
but you're wanting to step it up to be
an engineer
exactly yeah i work every day hand to
hand with engineers and all that so i
said to myself you know i'm so close i'm
a year and a half from having my degree
i should just give a shot to this you
know sacrifice whatever i need to
sacrifice and just go for it what's it
gonna cost to finish the degree in the
most at the most affordable school
possible
uh yeah and the current one that i have
is the is the cheapest one because it's
the same one that i have from puerto
rico
so it's gonna uh get me between uh
eighteen thousand dollars to finish for
that year and a half
yes sir
so we got 91 000 in debt and we have to
cash flow another 18.
yes sir um
can you do that
well i'm going to give it a shot i'm
getting some more overtime i'm getting
some side works i'm willing to do
whatever door does uh whatever it takes
so xavier i'm gonna say this in a meaner
way than george's because he's a kinder
human just in general than me
you are broke
i know you and your wife both have jobs
but you're in a precarious situation for
you and your family i absolutely think
it's a wise idea you're so close and
electrical engineers are is an ex it's a
remarkable credential and i love the
fact that you've been on the line for so
long you're gonna make a great
electrical engineer okay
um thank you and so i love that idea
but um where my sympathy is zero is i
got a second phd with two young kids and
i was working a full-time job and i was
doing adjuncting on the side and i
almost lost my marriage and so i don't
recommend it for long term and i was
pretty exhausted most of the time but
hey you figure it out and that's where
you are so for the next 24 months if you
do this
you have to you and your wife your wife
needs to do doordash too and also mow
lawns in the morning in the dark with a
headlamp or i don't know whatever y'all
need to do i need to figure this out
right so it's both hand i think yeah and
i think you could be making more as an
electrician and i know that because i
just paid one and i swear he looked like
he was 16 and i he still charged me 500
bucks so what are you making on your own
as an electrician
um 20 at the moment
20 28 an hour 28 an hour okay i was like
that feels uh wildly low but even 28 an
hour as electrician i think you could be
doing better is that with a company yeah
yeah i i just i just moved to orlando
was uh working in uh boca raton but we
moved here because i have to be uh on
campus for college okay so i just moved
here like two months ago
and i went from making 23 they bumped me
up to 28
and i know there's there's people pay
more so i'm i'm gonna look at that too i
would be i mean in your neighborhood
there's probably a facebook group and if
you offer up your services just in your
neighborhood alone you could be making
extra thousands of dollars on the
weekends doing little jobs for people
but it's just you understanding and you
sound like somebody that is not
has no fear of hard work
it's just you and your wife sitting down
y'all take one last um
one last go on one last date and just
say for the next 24 months we're gonna
hit the gas so that we can clear this
thing up forever yeah i think we gotta
clear this debt first before we cash
flow college and i want you to get that
engineering credential and make more
money and you can do that but right now
we got to clean up this mess thank you
so much for the call
julio joins us up next in dc julio
welcome to the show
oh thank you very much i appreciate you
taking my call sure what's going on um
so i've been listening to the ramsey
show for a little bit over a month month
and a half and i was very hesitant about
tackling my credit card debt just
because you know i was making my
payments and i had i had cash stockpiled
um i had 20k saved in the bank
and i was very hesitant to go ahead and
make those payments just because you
know you don't want to see all that cash
that you
you work so hard to save up
but of course the interest is killing
you right on had um i had
uh you're carrying the debt month to
month on the card
yes sir what was the interest rate
so i had a usaa card that was at 10 that
was at 9.6
and i had a chase card that was at 21.
yeah so
i would have loaned you money at 21
julio dang dude no
it made you feel so safe didn't it so
the one card the the usa card had 5500
on it and uh chase card had three grand
on it
um so the interest alone on the chase
card was like 58 a month
so i just i appreciate the advice i was
very like headstrong about it i was very
like hesitant about it um but i decided
to take the cash that i had saved
and i made two payments today for the
full balances for both cars
completely paid off
completely paid off both cards are ones
at zero and i guess the other payments
pending but yeah i made the transfers to
my bank and just um
yeah i paid both cards off today and and
i just wanted to say thank you for
for giving me that you know that road
that path okay hold on it's you're this
is still fresh on you
it's just yeah you are free my man
yes yes i am you are free julio yes i am
i'm debt free now so i mean i have i
have student loans now that i'm going to
tackle which aren't that much i think
it's it's like 3k and student debt that
i can actually pay off with with the
remainder i have 10 grand remaining from
the or 11 grand remaining
from the uh original amount so
you know i think that's that'll be gone
in a month or two right yes sir and then
instead of making payments to everybody
else to make them rich and buy them nice
houses and them nice buildings
you can replenish that account and then
some right roger roger that dude
congratulations my brother that's
awesome julio congratulations man thank
you for the call i love that john
because for every julio out there
there's another 20 of them going i'm
paying off the card today there's
another 200 000 of them i'm not safe i
got money in the bank but i owe these
lenders at 25
i'm not winning let's pay this thing off
let's run our own race and julio you're
a great example of that appreciate the
call brother congratulations on on this
journey you're you're doing it baby step
two the dead snowball it works every
time you work it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Music]
how many times have you found yourself
saying
one day when thinking about a goal that
you have one day i'll be able to buy a
house one day i'll be happy with my
career or one day i won't have to battle
with anxiety anymore stop waiting around
whatever your one day is you've got to
start now that's why we created smart
conference smart conference is the one
day event where we tackle all areas of
your life and guys let's face it we all
could use that kind of boost right now
you're going to hear from the nation's
top thought leaders on money career
mental health relationships marriage and
leadership and the event is hitting the
road we'll be going to dallas texas on
saturday october 22nd but you gotta
hurry because these event passes are
selling out fast platinum passes already
sold out but you can all you can still
get your general access passes for just
39
for an all-day event best-selling
authors and world-class speakers include
rachel cruz dr john dolone ken coleman
myself christina ellis dave ramsey we're
going to be there in full force not to
mention our friends and leadership
experts from life church craig and amy
grishell and a lot of surprises planned
too some great entertainment some great
music you don't want to miss it go to
ramseysolutions.com
events and get your passes today it is
worth a drive it is worth a flight
people come from all over to see this
event and it's been a while since we've
done it so don't miss it
ramseysolutions.com
events
brandon joins us up next in bowling
green kentucky brandon welcome to the
show
let's go to oh there he is brandon you
with us buddy
yes right here hey how you doing how can
we help
brandon i'm sorry george isn't great
with the technology i'm getting there he
is a millennial john just got an iphone
like a week ago for the first time that
is true he was on a black bear
what's going on sorry i didn't need to
catch up
so um a little over a year and a half
ago i was in a i was a passenger in a an
injury crash
and a piece of safety equipment uh
safety equipment malfunctioned uh
severely
i broke my neck i was on fire a bunch of
other things um so sorry so
um
and the reason i'm probably today is i
just received my first settlement offer
we we haven't uh didn't accept that yet
but
pretty soon i'll probably be accepting a
fairly large amount of money uh
multi-million dollar settlement
and i don't know what to do day one i'm
terrified that i you know i don't want
to mess this up
uh kind of just lost and trying to find
out what i need to do
and where to begin what have been the
long-term ramifications of the accident
are you able to work are you are you
paralyzed you able to get around what's
what's your state now
uh i'm still using a walker um the
doctor says i'm disabled you know
hopefully i can get beyond that but at
this point i'm not working okay
is the settlement contingent on you not
working
no it's not okay
um how much money are we talking
currently is the first offer
i was right around five million dollars
okay wow
well i'm so sorry to hear about the
accident how long ago was it a year and
a
half
okay and there's a lot of recurring
medical issues you're still dealing with
absolutely
absolutely it's been pretty devastating
well i'm so sorry about that piece on
the 5 million side you know i'm glad
you're taking your time with this and
you want you want to do it with a lot of
wisdom and that's the right way to go
about this is to move as slowly as
possible
don't touch this money until you really
need it obviously this is going to be
your income for the foreseeable future
and the good news is there's plenty of
it
if you use it wisely it can absolutely
last you the rest of your life
right do you uh do you have you how
you've
taken care of your rent and your bills
and things like that over the last few
years
uh
i had to move in with family we actually
lost our home after this uh
the bills were too high and uh my wife
was taking care of me full-time for
quite a while yeah so
uh living with family
and you know that that's obviously
something we don't want to do long term
yep
so she full-time caretaker or she
working outside the home
she she just is getting ready to go back
to work i'm finally getting to a place
where i can kind of take care of myself
man you got kids
two kids uh teenagers well 12 and 15
girls
okay you guys have any debt
no okay that's good you have any money
in savings
not at this point no okay so i would
break this up into two different two
different
parts here number one is what do we need
right now
and i would rather you and your wife
have that conversation not with five or
10 or 15 million dollars in your
checking account
because if you have that conversation
the van is going to be way newer and the
house is going to be way bigger right
right we're like hey we got
one of those shows those hdtv shows were
like trying to decide which house to buy
in their budget it's like tom and sue
are both 22 and their budget is nine
million dollars that's what it's gonna
feel like right so let's write down
here's what we need
we've got a home we're going to go ahead
and fit do the college funds we get
emergency fund like what's what's the
thing here and then we're going to sit
down directly with a smart investor pro
whether we're going to create a trust of
some sort or we're going to create some
sort of
income structure so that this replaces
your
income until you find long-term work
that makes sense
yes and george gave the magic word here
slow because you know as well as i do
the data on lottery winners and you have
you're not winning a lottery or anything
but it's really easy to get money just
to people will come out of the woods and
they hear you got 10 million dollars and
blah blah that money can go away so fast
so you and your wife making up a set of
boundaries and rules we are not going to
give this away right out of the gate
we're not going to do this right out of
the gate
we're going to send this to with sit
down with our smartvestor pro and get a
good retirement i mean get a good fund
set up for this thing
that's what we're gonna do with it but
we're gonna be very intentional very
slow so the only homework for you
brandon right now is to start assembling
your team because that's what you need
right now you need like a board of
trustees in a situation like this so i
want you to find uh and you can find
this all ramseysolutions.com click on
trusted pros but you need a really great
tax pro you need a great smartvestor pro
on the investing side not only for you
know your own personal investing but for
the kids and the 529s and getting them
to college you need a real estate pro
who knows what they're doing and you
need an insurance pro and you can
connect with all those people at
ramseysolutions.com
and along the way of course you can call
us back as this becomes more tactical
but i think your long-term plan is let's
buy a reasonable house with cash let's
get college fully funded for the kids
let's get a reasonable car to get around
with and the rest we're going to park in
investments long term and we're not
going to touch it like john said a trust
may be the best option for you with a
state of this size but that's where
smartvestor pro can help maybe a real
estate attorney a tax attorney you name
it and we're also going to be about
healing
um there's going to just continue to be
psychological physical healing you know
that and as your family re
[Music]
re-redesigns what life is going to look
like what normal is going to look like
moving forward
we're going to spend we're going to
continue to spend energy doing that but
good for you we're glad you're glad
you're turning the corner man and uh
give us a call and we'll walk alongside
you any way we can
man that's a tough situation john
now in situations like this where
there's a deep level of trauma and
there's a pile of money on this side
that can be a very stressful place to be
where you're just going like i'm trying
to grieve from this thing but i have to
deal with this giant pile of money yeah
and what this means for my life now i
mean it changes your life in a lot of
ways obviously it's better than having
no money right and having this situation
happen but it's a it's feels similar to
i lost a loved one and now there's life
insurance payout that i get right the
money obviously is never going to equate
to what happened right with this
situation but how does someone
grieve that process while navigating you
said it best it it well the grief is one
thing that's something you you walk
through with counseling and thinking
your community and your friends and your
church if you've got one and a
professional if you need one right so
there's that
what happens often in a situation like
this is
he
has it feels tremendous guilt for being
disruptive for having to move in with
his family for his kids having to go
through x y and z and then suddenly you
got five million dollars an account or
that's a rare example that's so far
outside the bell curve let's say you get
a hundred thousand dollars the
temptation to
buy your kids a super nice car as a way
of paying to feel guilty right or to
make sure they've got this much money in
college fund or we're going to get them
this nice of a house in this
neighborhood because we finally can
it's not looking at the money like you
won the lottery it's looking at this
money like this is going to keep us
plugging and moving down the street
right and it like these settlements are
to make you whole this is going to bring
us back to where we were and so i'm
going to make sure we're stable and then
we're going to create a very intentional
intentional budget
and then we're going to let this money
just stay over here
a lot of wisdom in that it's tough
thanks for the call brandon we're
wishing the best for you
healing wise and for your financial
future and for your family this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm george campbell joined today by dr
john deloney this is the ramsey show the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'll talk about
your life your money your relationships
your mental health all of it it happens
right here on the ramsay show
john joins us up next in st louis john
welcome to the show
hi guys thank you so much it's such a
pleasure to speak with you guys
absolutely how can we help yeah so
so yeah so dr john um you know this
question is primarily for you i just
want to thank you first off um you know
i read your book i think you're
absolutely fantastic
i find myself in a little bit of a
situation here i'm trying to find
financial peace even after following the
baby steps
so
really quickly i'm 32 years old all
deaths paid off including my home
however i recently just had a
transmission go out in my car
and that same kind of panic and that
same fear that i had
came right back and the fact that i had
to take that on my fully funded
emergency fund so i was just kind of
looking to kind of see what your guys's
guidance would be on how to kind of help
tackle that kind of that fear and that
anxiety even after following baby steps
that's a great question man tell me
about how money worked when you were a
kid
uh there was no discussion on money um i
lived in a very very
very uh poor household there was no
doubt about it
and so there was no discussion of money
i started off out of college
very very rough student loans you name
it i was just guided guided in the wrong
direction
and i got out of that cool
um and then are you married
i am married i have two kids you got two
kids okay uh what was your wife's
situation like
uh pretty much the same just
well she had she has a loving family
absolutely fantastic um she only had a
little bit of college debt and just a
little bit of credit card debt but
that's been paying off so she has a
completely different
upbringing than mine was so i'm gonna
oversimplify this because we're just
having a few minutes on the on the radio
is that cool
yeah that's fine all right so let's take
your situation and you grew up in a
house where we don't talk about money
it's a
dark cloud over the house there's never
enough of it and there's a lot of stress
that even as a young kid you know
we don't have fill in the blank right
right
your body put a gps pin in that
right
it put a pin in it and said this is not
safe
and
so
you discovered this
when it
let's say let's say you're 25. um you
discover the baby steps suddenly you get
a path out of this of this
i'm not safe i'm not safe i'm not safe
i'm not safe i don't have any control in
my life
and you get a path out
your brain still understands that a
money issue is not only a money issue
it's a relationship issue it's
catastrophic and it is just scanning its
environment 24 7 365 looking for the
next thing that might get you and it
remembers that money stuff gets you
right and so
now you are free
and
you ever been on a boat
all day on a boat
nope never been on boat okay if you're
on a boat and you're going fishing or
skiing
what you don't realize is the water is
kind of rocking all day and when you get
off that boat you stand on the shore and
it
it feels weird for a little bit because
your body has to get used to the world's
not moving underneath you anymore
and so the word i want to give you is
practice
you are safe and you know the math
problem your frontal lobe right the
front part of your brain knows that
you're safe
the part that doesn't is the part that's
been trying to keep you safe and keep
you alive since you're a little kid
and what we're going to do is we're
going to practice every time that alarm
system sounds oh no it's all coming down
you can stop
and take a big deep breath and hold it
for a second and exhale
and say we got emergency fun we're good
and we're just gonna practice it and
we're gonna practice it we're gonna
practice it here's what you have you
have an identity that says i'm poor
i have an identity that says i'm not
safe and what you have to do is lean
into and learn a new identity and we we
say all the time like
or if you just scroll instagram it'll
tell you just decide man you can just
decide but you gotta practice it right
like i'm gonna be a great basketball
player doesn't mean i'm gonna wake up
tomorrow and be a great basketball
player i'm gonna lose a hundred pounds
cool it's gonna take you nine months
right so you are gonna have to practice
leaning into this new identity and it's
going to be consciously aware of those
thoughts when they take off on you
write them down if you want to if you
want to up the annie if you want to
super up to annie commit to your wife
hey when both because she's going to
feel the same things when either one of
us has a
money thing set off our alarm system
let's commit to telling the other person
because the other person can then hold
our hands and say good thing we have an
emergency fund good thing we're safe
good thing now we are just paying
ourselves for whatever we want because
we have no payments you see what i'm
saying right right absolutely i want you
to i want you to hear me very clearly
you're not broken
you're not dysfunctional
you're not malfunctioning
okay
your brain is just trying to keep you
safe and what it needs to learn is i am
safe now is that cool yes sir congrats
hey absolutely you have changed
an entire legacy you know that right
right
you're gonna watch your kids as they
have a different experience in their
home a different one than you and um
you're gonna it will heal you over time
in a pretty profound and beautiful way
so congratulations for changing
everything now you gotta
walk on the ground understanding that
it's not shaking underneath it anymore
way to go man beautifully said john yeah
those kids when dad's going hey kids
here's how money works we just had this
thing happen with the car and we had the
money to pay for it we don't have to
stress and wonder where that money's
gonna come from the kids then learn
oh that's okay to talk about money and
the way to avoid having stress with
money is having it in the bank and not
having to rely on other people's money
so the lessons that can be learned from
this are awesome and i would encourage
john uh he sounds like he's a saver
because he's very worried it's not going
to be enough so i'd encourage him to
spend it on purpose like you said
practice practice spending money right
even though it's leaving your bank
account you have plenty of it and
practice giving yes because it'll give
you joy with money instead of money's a
thing i have to hold on to because what
if what if what if instead you're
practicing all three give save spend
that's what we talk about on the show
and it's a healthy practice george i see
people a lot whether it's leadership
whether it's parenting i talked to
somebody on my show earlier today that
was
saying hey i think i lost my mother jean
now um because my my youngster is three
and she wants to sleep with me but i
need a nice sleep right
we constantly think that if we run up
against something we don't understand
that we're somehow got character issues
we're a failure we're a loser we suck at
the
it's often i just don't have that skill
set i just don't know to do that i've
never been in a position to do this
right and so if you've never taken a
free throw with 15 000 people cheering
you on you don't know what that pressure
is like you know what i mean so be
really gracious with yourself i have
never been in a situation where i have a
transmission flat on my car and it's
annoying not um catastrophic not i might
get hit by a dad who's had too many
drinks not but i fill in the blank right
um so let's give ourselves some grace
and start practicing living into these
new identities man it's gonna be great
yeah i was just meeting with our
research team yesterday and they were
unpacking some of the data from our
latest personal finance study and it was
fascinating to see the direct quotes of
how people are feeling around money and
it was an interesting connection so uh
it was about 48 said i can't get ahead
with my finances that's how they were
feeling 45 said i feel ashamed of the
way i handled money in the past and
another chunk about a third said i wish
i was taught how to handle money well
and there's an interesting connection
there i feel like i'll never get ahead
because i feel shameful about how i've
spent in the past because i wasn't
taught how to handle money told me how
to yeah and so we you just need to
relearn and practice and it doesn't have
to stay this way yeah but it starts with
a decision going
i'm not going to be like my parents
sometimes it's the anti-mentor right
i don't want to be how my parents were
stressed out the first time i i
said yeah i'll uh i'll change my son's
diaper
i did not know how diapers worked that's
me being vulnerable america i didn't
know how they worked and i tried to put
one on and i think on yourself nope on
my on my son okay thank you for uh it
was not i did not do a good job it would
not have been an effective use of that
diaper um
and now you're an expert i'm i'm pretty
good at it but my wife came and said oh
um that's not gonna work and so i had to
practice i had to learn how to do it
right it wasn't because i'm the worst
ever and i'm gonna lose nah it's got
practice man and so many of those things
we just gotta practice just gotta get
ahead i gotta change that mindset i'm
somebody who's gonna win with money i'm
somebody who's gonna get ahead with
money so i gotta practice those things
that are gonna make that happen
yeah and james clear talks about this in
atomic habits of you know values
identity-based goals where you go i'm
the kind of person who blank that's
right and it changes the way you look at
money when you do that yeah like i call
the first one of the first callers
i am a kind of person who never borrows
money
so i'm not going to go into debt for
school or whatever the thing is yeah
that's huge good hour john appreciate
all the folks in the booth keeping the
show afloat and you america thank you so
much for listening we'll be back with
you before you know it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
ramsey personality george campbell
joined today by dr john doloni and we
are excited even pumped to take your
calls
825-5225 is the number to call we'll
talk about money life relationships
boundaries horses rock and roll it's
your show america i before we take a
call what
we're pumped huh yeah nope i decided i'm
gonna be nice to george we are pumped
america i like pumped
what else would you say john enthused
i'm just i can we just say happy
no we have to say pumpkin we're happy to
take her like we're an old basketball
was somebody found in the in the yard
put some errands when you drive you call
the shots you normally say stoked like
you're 12 years old yeah i'm jazz dude
jazz stoked choose your own boy he said
see you later boy see like i'm jazzed
i'm stoked i'm ready to rock and roll
or i'm pumped all right we know how john
feels now thank you for that cool i'm a
deflated basketball ready to go get it
america let's do this move on to someone
who hopefully likes me more than john
and it's jw in atlanta what's up jw
hey how's it going guys great how can
jon and i help today
so
i just
heard of the ramsey method and dave
ramsey
this past week so i'm very new to
everything welcome to the gang man
yeah yeah i feel like
i i've been doing the ramsey method my
whole life but didn't know that somebody
was out there doing it some some people
call it common sense
it doesn't seem to be very common
anymore you're correct you're correct
but i'm i'm debt free um i do owe on my
house i owe about three years left and i
have my house paid off i'm 31 years old
i've got college accounts for two of my
kids which is all of my children i've
got my roth ira
my roth ira and 401k accounts
i've been saving for retirement since 18
and i've been stacking my money away but
right now i'm struggling because
i want to buy a camper for my family uh
we like to go camping but
i have
two little girls five and seven
and between my little girls and my wife
i've been told that we're done camping
if there's not air conditioning and a
toilet that they don't have to walk to
in the dark hey i'm with him it's
ridiculous jw you don't have to put up
with this john thinks he's bear grylls
out there and i'm you know my parents
didn't immigrate to this country so i
could sleep in the woods with no toilet
that's how i feel george camps at a
marriott all right
[Laughter]
he's like hey honey tonight
no room service we're gonna rush me
slumming it is like we're going to the
days in we're really going to rush it
right i love it so jw what's this camper
going to cost
uh
well i've never bought anything with a
payment and i'm not going to this time
either
i've got about eight or nine thousand
dollars
that i could spend on it that's outside
of your emergency fund
yeah okay
so what i'm wondering is
should i go ahead and buy the camper
enjoy the memories with my kids while
they're still little
or should i take that money and put it
on the house and try to knock another
year off of
paying for a house and try to put it off
down the road for a couple more years
i
let me just answer how i've done this in
my house okay and then george can
actually give you real wisdom with
actual math okay
um
i
have a very similar situation to you my
kids are six and 12. okay
um i chose to split the difference and
what i've chose to do is we now go to
campsites that have like a little cabin
that we can rent that has little air
conditioners in them and that has been a
lifesaver for in fact that's been a fun
game changer for me and my family
because i love camp and i love being
outside my wife's actually way better
camper than me i'm actually more like
george than i care to admit um but it's
also it's just a pain right and there's
it's a hassle that when you're traveling
with kids and stuff and all that so
um we have found some really remarkable
success going to koas across the country
and staying in cabins next to lakes and
rivers and all kinds of stuff and we get
the get to close the door get air
conditioner and i don't have a payment
of a camper i will own a camper at some
point and it will be cool and it will be
nice i'm choosing in my house to pay my
house off before i go buy a camper i
don't know george and i'm looking to you
that that's wrong the other way around i
don't think in this situation there's
there's a right or wrong exactly right
you saved up and paid cash and you're in
baby steps four through six
there's nothing wrong there you're still
being very intentional but to john's
point i probably wouldn't go out and
spend 50 grand on a camper and spending
nine grand on the camper is not going to
get you much of a camper if we're going
to be honest yeah campers are expensive
right now with a you know a bathroom
yeah well
they're used to me being a cheap ass
i know i'm not hey my family is too
brother my family is two
um yeah they they know they know there's
gonna have to be some work to be done
most of this thing when we buy it before
we can ever take it out because we're
gonna get a deal
right um it may be that um
you
camp with your buddies
and you take them all again it's one of
those things that like i've got this
picture of my life and now that once my
kids reach a certain age i have to be an
adult enough to say okay my picture of
what we're going to be doing is going to
be very different and i had these
pictures of my daughter and the deer
blind with me and my wife
it's not going to happen and so i have
to just grieve that for a second like ah
man and then i gotta be about okay
what's the thing what's the right thing
for our family now um i would not put
nine grand into a crummy trailer with
the idea that i'm gonna fix it up and
please all the women in my house jw
what's your income
household
uh
well it's just me that works um i make
about 70 000 a year
okay
and uh what vehicles do you have right
now anything with a motor in it
uh
right now i've got my truck
what's that what's it add up to as far
as the worth of those vehicles
oh
six thousand dollars between both of
them wow
jw i probably enjoy your life i would
probably upgrade those before buying a
camper
yes well this is brand new baby i just
got it
hey and uh george asked a great question
i forgot about i have a buddy of mine
who bought an incredible camper and that
meant he then had to go buy an f-350 to
pull it and so the camera turned into a
whole other purchase too right
yeah yeah i i've been looking and i can
find small ones that
i can pull behind my truck no problem
and
you know the question is your family
going to want to stay in that because it
sounds like you're going to get the
dumpiest camper ever and they're going
to have a miserable time and they were
better off camping in the backyard j.w
you're a man after my heart my brother
this guy i know you're one of my
favorite calls i ever took hey keep
being here's the thing
sit down with your wife and get to the
bottom of it okay what's what's a good
vacation for our family and if you need
some woods time which i'm a guy who does
i need that um that might be something
that you do separate apart or take one
kid with you or something like that and
family vacations family time
may look differently and i will tell you
this my brother having learned this the
hard way
it's okay to spend money on time away
with your family i have been the
cheapest
uh i'm ashamed at myself when i look
back and see how i have neglected i'm
going to do some nice things going on
some trips going on some vacations in
the sake of i'm gonna save this money
you gotta save this oh i got a deal i
gotta keep on on top of it
dude just take your wife out take your
kids out and if you have to have to go
get a cabin at koat for a couple yeah
just budget for if you want to go
camping seven times a year just budget
for that and go all right it's gonna be
a thousand times each time we do that
thousand bucks seven thousand dollars
for the year we can do that every year
and it's still cheaper than buying a
real nice camper way cheaper and go rent
your buddies which is sitting in his
driveway that he uses way less than he
thought he would and he'll give it to
you for 200 bucks for the weekend there
you go this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
dot
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell host of the fine print and
entree leadership podcast joined today
by dr john dolone host of the dr john
deloney show you can find all of those
shows on the ramsay network youtube
podcast you name it we are there for you
it's a free call today triple eight
eight two five five two two five graham
joins us up next in grand rapids graham
welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call happy to
take it what's going on
so i was looking at ramsey's solutions
website in regards to investing and
i saw that randy solutions advocates for
mutual funds and
is very against bonds as an asset to use
and i was curious to if you could flesh
out why that is
i read some articles on the website but
i didn't find them fully satisfactory
mm-hmm so i wanted that
what's not satisfactory i'd love to hear
your take
so it really came down to
the lack of
return of investment rate of return
and i know it's the most important
metric with an
but it's not the only metric
and i
it felt a little
one dimensional in its analysis
meaning in your analysis being there's
the other side which is the perception
that bonds are somehow a
uh
it's like it's like when you buy drywall
that's fireproof like this will stop the
fire and it's like it's so it's your
protection right
it's so much protection it's that the
bonds is serving a slight
function than say a mutual fund or an
index fund
so why why are you clearly you're a fan
of bonds so tell us what your reasoning
is for
wanting to invest in them
well i'm a fan of bonds only to the
extent that
it seems to be a good idea to include
them in a portfolio but i'm not
advocating for an all bonds portfolio
sure
i mean we're very counter-cultural we're
weird in a whole lot of ways
bonds bonds excluded but financial
advisors what they do is over time as
you get older they want to put you in
more bonds to create safety which guess
what creates safety for their jobs
because you're not knocking down their
door when you're going well i lost money
and i'm about to be in retirement age
and so that's a very counter cultural
thing where we go no keep investing
diversify your portfolio four types of
mutual funds growth aggressive growth
growth and income international and
you're going to be better off in the
long term so i'll here's what i'll tell
you i'll answer the uh
personal question let george kind of
walk you through it
i have no bonds in my personal portfolio
none zero
okay so that's that's how i'm choosing
to do with me and my family and so this
isn't like a like we got some company
statement that we're making this is how
i how i choose because the idea that
it's somehow a protection or some how a
hedge against a riskier
investment simply isn't it's not
mathematically accurate right it's a
debt product
right but
i don't
i guess i see it as more of a fixed
income and that's what
that's what
the ninja it's the fixed income it's not
some
appreciation or that's debt or that i
don't even see it i think every asset is
inherently risky even treasury bonds
right we i think we could all agree on
that so i guess it's i was just curious
where that just made with the risk
reward but
um
i just wasn't sure how i felt about so
see what your guys's thoughts were
yeah i mean like we talked about the
returns you're going to get from bonds
are not impressive you're going to do
better in the stock market than in the
bond market and they're going to barely
outpace inflation and we want you to
beat the market so you can build wealth
and so when it comes to fixed income
if i have five million because i had all
of my money in the stock market and none
in bonds and you've got three million
because you were heavier in bonds well
i'm going to have a higher fixed income
with my five million sitting there even
if it fluctuates a little bit with the
stock market but over time we're going
to see the stock market continue to grow
the economy is going to continue to grow
long term over a long period of time and
that's how we look at investing and by
the way if you buy a bunch of bonds when
they're cheap and interest rates go up
you're going to be unable to move those
bonds because the value has gone down
all it's yes going back to your original
thing this is the idea of a
um
it's like remember when when the
government gave put out the food pyramid
years ago
and come to find out there was mostly
lawyers who made that determination of
what should be in the food pyramid
you're saying we shouldn't eat a ton of
milk and sugar john i'm saying that milk
sugar shouldn't make up the bulk of your
diet um all that is but this is not a
nutrition show so
now all the nutrition
zealots are going to come at us what i'm
saying is there is a there is a picture
that's been sold to us that is this is
the balanced portfolio
and this is what this looks like we
could go into a whole bond segment i
don't think that's worth the time what
i'm saying is
understand that bonds don't provide like
well you've got to have your dessert
otherwise it's not a complete meal what
i'll say is at the end of the day it's
just it's not healthy let's move on yeah
and there are some nerdy studies out
there that i've looked at where it's
comparing hey if you just stayed in the
stock market with more aggressive
investing strategies versus putting it
in bonds you're going to end up ahead in
the long term it's a theory that doesn't
pan out in reality yes and again
financial advisors want this because
it's job security for them so that
you're not angry when you lose some
money in retirement they want to make it
safer for you as you go there but then
you've got no return in retirement which
means that money is going to run out a
lot faster
because your retirement remember you
might live to 95 and retire at 60. so
you need that money to continue growing
at the pace that was growing from 60 to
95
versus it running out at 70. so it's a
great question
uh and if you're not satisfied with the
website i mean we can agree disagree
it's okay we can still be friends thanks
for the call man angel joins us up next
in irvine angel welcome to the show
please don't sing john
what's up guys how you doing good you
hey thank you thank you for taking my
call man of course
right so
so my question is this uh
my wife and i were immigrants from spain
uh we've been here for
about 20 years
uh you know everything has been great we
discovered you guys about six years ago
we started paying off all of our debt
and now we are on baby step number three
uh we believe we should be done with it
by november this year
and so
we have a lot of certainty
in that we are going to spend our
retirement back in spain in may you know
maybe 25 years from now 20 to 25 years
from now
uh we're currently renting
so we don't have a house we don't own
property
and so my main question would be will it
make sense for us to make an investment
on a house right now
or
should we focus on on our retirement
well i think you can do both you have
any money in retirement
so
currently we have uh saved up
about uh forty thousand dollars
in betting
i'm 44. my wife is 39
uh in our household income is about 175.
awesome um
and so
well that's really thanks to you guys i
mean the the method really works john
and i did nothing man you didn't do
anything angel you did it so here's what
i'm seeing angel i would absolutely
invest in a home in the u.s i mean you
said you're not going to retire in spain
for 25 years and so think about what
rent's going to do in 25 years in
california versus you investing 15
percent of your income in retirement
after you get your fully funded
emergency fund then saving up for that
house down payment as quickly as
possible and then locking in a fixed
expense with a 15-year uh conventional
mortgage
and paying that thing off before you
retire in spain and then think about
what the appreciation on that home will
be 25 years from now in california or
wherever you live and you go sell that
home and go retire with a giant pile of
cash and no payments for a long time
that sounds like a great
so it would make us it would make sense
then okay and for investment then i
should just follow uh 15 of your income
yeah rules don't overthink mutual funds
yeah okay once you get a paid for home
you can ramp up that 15 and go harder on
that and really start to you know
ratchet it up if you guys want to retire
earlier but you're doing great stay on
the path and definitely let's get the
emergency fund beefed up get the
retirement beefed up and get you in a
home long term so that you're not trying
to keep up with rent for 25 years way to
go man
more your calls coming up on the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well john you know this august is
national make a will month
and we are celebrating all month long
if you don't have an up-to-date will as
a part of your estate plan what are you
waiting for you need to knock this out
right now but here's the thing there's
more to estate planning than just having
a will estate planning covers all of the
documents plans and conversations you
need to have in case something happens
to you and no you don't have to be an
eccentric millionaire with an offshore
account to have an estate plan it
wouldn't hurt but you don't need it so
that means you need an estate plan
because a good estate plan protects your
family's future and it's easy to put
yours together with the right tools and
we've got a great estate planning guide
for you that's free and easy to use
it'll help you keep track of everything
you need and it walks you through
exactly which documents to get like if
you will
like your will if you don't have one
what conversations to have and where you
can go to get more info so you can knock
this stuff off your list so give
yourself and your loved ones peace of
mind by figuring this stuff out ahead of
time you can download your complete
guide to estate planning for free at
ramseysolutions.com
estate guide that's ramsey solutions.com
estate guide before we before we go on
from here if if you've if you're new to
the show let me say this
a friend of mine named john says
the only reason to not have a will
is if you hate your wife and kids
and
i think he's exactly right
the number of people i've sat with in
the middle of the night whose husbands
have died or whose wives have passed
away who look at me and say
i don't know what to do uh we have
nothing i got to go to work on monday i
can't count that number of people have a
will you can go to mama bear i mean just
have a wheel go to mama bear wheels get
a wheel done you can do it in a not very
long time at your kitchen table and
knock it out right absolutely or you can
go to more drawn out process you can get
a full estate
get a will i'm a single person get a
will i'm we're newlyweds how many kids
get a will there's no reason none who it
wills for breathing people a hundred
percent of us are gonna die none of us
get out of this thing right
we'll find a way george love we'll find
a way
man well i just saw this article it's
been blowing up uh prince his the you
know the artist his estate formerly
known as finally it came to an end 156
million dollar estate this crazy battle
because he didn't have a will in place
156 million dollars and six years later
they finally ironed it out after a lot
of pain and suffering so i don't know
about you george
but over the last few years i haven't
been i'd say over the last 10.
i haven't been just overwhelmed by the
government's performance on just
multiple issues
now some things are great some things
i'm like wow they built a great park in
my neighborhood you know and when you
don't have a will
you are saying you know who i want to
take care of my wife and kids when i'm
gone you know who i want to take care of
my family
i want the government to do it they're
doing a bang-up job all across
everything else i see let's let them go
ahead and take care of my most prized
possessions like my most prized
relationships on the planet i want to
make sure they'll they'll take care of
it don't do that no thanks tom hanks
that's what i say no thanks tom hanks at
the bank i'm trying to catch him frank
i'm trying to make a catch on that stank
well thank you for that reminder john
get a will and uh you can check out the
state guide once again ramsay solutions
dot com slash estate guy it's completely
free
all right brian joins us in oklahoma
city brian welcome to the show
thanks guys uh so i just had a few
questions for you guys
all right
we have a few answers let's do it yes i
well i hope so
so currently me and my household
at single income it's about 56 000 a
year
and
so before we got on on to financial
peace university and everything else i
actually didn't even know that y'all
show until i got the new vehicle
and um
that was about 20 000 into debt and
so after watching um the first couple of
episodes on the financial peace
university
um
we thought it was more lucrative for us
to
change the baby steps for us from one to
two and do it backwards
pay off our debt first and then
save because our budget's real tight and
we wouldn't have been able to save the
thousand dollars
completely up for like
four or five months and i felt like that
was way too long
for us to try to
save up a thousand dollars versus
keeping
credit cards and not paying more on our
car that we could have paid over that
time what what do you guys think about
that
well brian uh my brain hurts because you
just said the word lucrative while also
saying you have zero dollars in the bank
while you pay off debt how is this a
money-making scheme to you
so well i don't miss i don't necessarily
think it's a money-making scheme i think
it's more along the lines of
um it's going to help us
pay off debt faster and then we can save
afterwards what happens if you get a
flat tire
well i i have a side job that i make
about 500 bucks a weekend on that's your
emergency fund dude that's it
500 bucks a week so you can two weeks
you'll have a thousand bucks ta-da
right well
and that's that's kind of
what what i had always thought um but
that that was aside from our regular
household income because the other thing
is djing weddings and so it doesn't
necessarily
always happen but all of your all of
your income all of your income all of it
side hustles um front hustles back
hustles top hustles bottom hustle all
the hustles
all that jumps into is your household
income so if you have a household income
of 56 000 and you make an extra 500
bucks a week you're gonna toss that on
top of that and all that together is is
piled in there okay
okay brian i don't know
i'm listening to the story i don't see
this as an exception to the rule i don't
see you as unique or special here you
save up a thousand dollars then we
attack the debt using the debt snowball
from smallest to largest ignoring the
interest rate and uh i might look at
selling this car what's it worth
uh i have no idea what it was we just
bought it i think in uh
in may
um before i even found out about call
and see what you can get for it if you
can get uh if you can get uh even steven
for it then
go sell it and then buy something half
the price you have another car
uh yeah it's a it's a beer car and i
mean it's paid off um but i i put a lot
of miles on it uh going back and forth
to weddings and i drive it back forth to
work the other car is
like our sacred car we don't really take
it anywhere if we don't have to there it
is the sacramento there's no such thing
as a sacred coup it's a depreciating
asset it's a piece of metal that's going
down in value every day there's nothing
sacred about it yes and um don't keep a
car payment in a nice car for a side
hustle
i had to and my wife get out of debt i
don't tell the story a lot because it
makes me sad and it makes me want to cry
george i had to sell a couple of my
guitars
and so it may be that you look at your
nice dj table and say hey i haven't been
djing i'm going to sell my gear and get
a thousand dollar emergency fund sell
everything until you get that thousand
bucks how much total that figure it out
oh uh we only have about
23 000 in debt including the car what's
the other you said 20 on the car what's
the other three uh they're like just
some small credit cards okay so listen
dude if you sold the car
and then you worked uh six weeks on your
side hustle you're debt free you're done
you're free
right before the car before we got the
car we were only a couple thousand
dollars in the hat but we we didn't
really have a good car
for us to use and it was more of a
headache to try to find a good used one
so and it was real hard for us to get
find anything because we have that
credit and before david ramsey before we
found out about financial peace
university
we really didn't know
you know the principles of
well
now you know brian ignorance was bliss
until now now you know can we just say
this you you've had tough you've got
tough credit you've had a bad
experiences with money i haven't been
wise with it
let me just ask you this point blank
have your ways worked
as in finances
yes are you happy with where you are
financially
do you feel like you're crushing it
i feel like i could do better i don't
think i'm crushing it but i know that
i'm not doing it that's all we're here
to do is help you do better that's what
i hope you do better man in this this
program millions of people have done it
we the baby steps are in the order they
are because they've been tried and trued
over millions of people and you're no
exception and if you go all in on this
i'm telling scorched earth we're doing
the baby steps exactly as is we're not
special we're going to be one of those
tens of millions of people who changes
our family tree sells the car sell some
gear do whatever it takes man it will
change your financial situation and even
better it's going to change you it's
going to change how you make decisions
stop singing yeah but yeah yeah just go
do it go do it you got this man let us
know if we can help along the way this
is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsey personality george campbell
joined today by my colleague dr john
deloney that's a ken coleman word for
you john colleague i was going to call
you my good friend but i'll go with
colleague i like that very professional
that's how we keep it here on the show
richard joins us up next in vegas
richard what's going on
how are you doing gentlemen great how
can we help
excellent so here's the deal i am uh i'm
24. i've been with this girl for a while
we're looking at uh we're looking at
getting married and we want to uh
we want to buy a house uh we want to do
it the right way we want to
uh
uh we want to do it without needing a
credit score i i've avoided
but we're newly started in our careers
and
have no idea how to how to pay for a
house if we're not doing it the uh i
guess the traditional method with a fico
score and all that all crap you came to
the right place my friend excellent i
did this uh in 2019 got a house without
a credit score paid off the mortgage
life is good and so let me walk you
through this how much what's your income
do you know what it'll be when you're
married
uh yeah it'll be
between uh 60 and 70 000 in that
ballpark okay cool you guys have any
debt
i have uh i have 16 000 in student loans
and 4 000
in a car what do y'all do for a living
she is a hair stylist and i am a
magician of all things
this just got interesting
so you do me is this full-time work
it is okay what do you make versus her
do you know
we both make in uh in around 35 000
years because it's vegas there's a a
decent amount of variance with uh with
the tipping industry sure um so that's
why i say in the 60 to 70 000 but but in
in about the 35 000 ballpark each and uh
we're both again we just started our
careers uh so i don't expect to make 35
000 for the rest of my life but uh
uh but it's a start okay cool i love
this is fantastic i love magicians
they're the best the best
the best so what is uh you know if she
has any debt
she does not okay so we're looking at 20
000 total in debt and looking at 70 000
household income
so how quickly can we pay off all of
this debt and start saving up for the
down payment
i have been i've been trying to put as
much money
towards it as i can
um you know i don't have a full 70 000
right now i have you know 35 000 sure i
think i can i can get it paid off from
my own personal income in a matter of
probably two or three years
okay so two to three years this thing's
paid off i want you to do it in two and
if that means side hustles if that means
something else let's do that but i think
three years is for 20 grand we can get
this thing cleaned up in two years
that's 10 grand a year are you able to
drive in the evenings or
do pickups in the morning or are you
able to squeeze in side hustles there it
seems like a job like um uber ubereats
would be a perfect
side hustle to what you're doing
uh
uh that is yeah that's a possibility i
can actually
uh i won't bore you with the details but
i can actually kind of fight hustle
magic as a street performer i think
which is here's
i'm gonna one-up george i want this
thing gone in 12 months i want this
thing going on in may at the max 16
months i want you to put that on a
calendar and reverse engineer and say
how much money do i have to make every
month and work on it like your life
depends on it because it kind of does
because you're one
more shut down from being in oh crap
land right
yes sir let's get this stuff all done
man let's just knock it out and let's
have one crazy year you'll look back and
remember the time we were nuts when i
was 24 and then when i was 25 i was free
and then you can go do real magic right
are you engaged yet richard
uh not officially no okay it's a magic
ring george that's a magic so we're
talking you know
maybe marriage is on the horizon a year
from now you have a wedding
yeah there there abouts um we've been
concerned with uh money's been a big
thing and just you know business um
we've been scared if i'm being
completely honest we're absolutely
terrified
uh
so
i haven't i haven't uh gotten down on
the knee and officially asked the
question but it's it's going to happen
absolutely well do that when the time is
right but i think we need to pause i
love that you're excited to get in a
home but it's going to be years from now
and that's okay a couple years away dude
so get that thousand dollar starter
emergency fund beyond that any money
goes towards the debt let's clean up
this debt in a year or two uh then let's
start make sure we cash flow the wedding
no debt there cash flow the ring and
then be about the business of getting
three to six months of expenses saved up
in an emergency fund and then and only
then do we start saving up for that down
payment and you're gonna have a lot more
margin in your life you're going to be
making more money and have no payments
and so i want you to save up you know 10
down would be great 20 would be even
better to avoid private mortgage
insurance where you're just throwing
money away to the lender and then make
sure you get a 15-year fixed-rate
conventional mortgage with a payment
that's no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay
you get all those numbers we got them
all on our website as well
i know i threw a lot at you there hey
that's what the path looks like i'm
writing this down but if you got it on
the website i will uh i'll look up there
richard let me let me tell you this
here's here's what this is going to look
like in real life this is you sitting
down with the woman who's about to be
your fiance
and
probably get engaged and then you'll sit
down and say here's what life's going to
look like
i want you all to grieve it
you know it'd be really cool to be to
get married she's a hair stylist for the
stars in vegas and you're you've got
your name on a big thing y'all aren't
there yet and so grieve it it'd be super
cool we're 25 and married with a big
dope house here in vegas it's not gonna
happen
so let's grieve it let's let's go out to
dinner and be like this is our sad
dinner and then after that we're gonna
be get real excited about our one
bedroom apartment that we can actually
afford and when we afford it we're gonna
feel safe
and we're not going to spend the first
two or three years panicked and worried
about hey are you working why are you
sitting down you should be out cutting
here we can't make the rent and we're
going to have unnecessary fights and
stress
and drama in our new wedding in a new
marriage that doesn't need any more
stress than it's already gonna have
you see what i'm saying so we're gonna
lean into this thing and then we're
gonna be happy about the one bedroom
apartment because we can afford it and
then we're gonna be about um working
these careers and grinding and grinding
and grinding until one day me and george
come out to vegas to see richard uh like
wait is it good to see your show hey
yeah when you hit it you let us know and
you send us some dude we'll be there
it'll be a blast i'm willing to pay for
the tickets but you can give this for
free it'd be great
george is the guy i think i will pay for
my ticket actually no you send me my
tickets yeah i think there's nothing
wrong with especially once you get
married you gotta adjust to a whole new
lifestyle so let's just rent for a while
getting into a home can be very
stressful there's a lot of costs uh a
lot of things associated with it so it's
totally okay to rent for a year or two
after you're married and let's start
saving up that down payment let's not
rush into this thing with nothing down
while we still have debt that is a
recipe for disaster financially and
maritally and i actually would tell if
he had said hey i've got 200 000 ready
to put down on a house i'm gonna get
engaged and get married i would say hey
i would do my best to talk him into
pausing pause
rent just just get to know one another
man and you think we've been dating for
five years
when you start brushing teeth next to
each other everything's different right
you're gonna start to see all the ticks
and all the quirks and this is where
john puts his laundry in the corner of
the room yes and if you've married
somebody that has a lot of tics
i was thinking of the bugs because i
live out in the woods oh yeah literally
john has to worry about this is why i
don't go to john's house exactly and
because i don't invite you with that too
yeah there we go
well it's a good reminder john for those
that are there's a lot of people who are
excited about i want to get married i'm
going to get a house and life's going to
be so great we're gonna have this dual
income
but when you do it and you still have
debt and you're trying to get the house
and now we feel like we need to upgrade
in car and look at our married friends
are doing it caused us so much drama and
pressure yeah and we just need to slow
down and run our own race yeah i had a
great line the other day on the show i
don't remember it but it was something
you've already dropped no thanks tom
hanks and so you're one for one it was
when you run other people's race there
is no finish line
that was that's a good line
i'm sure we can agree to disagree all
right
fine if i tweeted that i'd get at least
three retweets though and two of them
would be your mother
one of them he's not on twitter joke's
on you john
sweet may uh when you got when you guys
got married did you move directly into a
house no town home we had an apartment
and we started saving up aggressively
and i was doing side gigs i was like
hosting outside events i was doing
marketing consulting i was building
websites i was going how can we stack up
as much money as we can for this down
payment and then we also went let's get
a really reasonable house because the
bank said they'd give us like half a
million dollars yeah we're not going to
do that
and so going for a very reasonable
mortgage on a reasonable house it
doesn't need to be a five-bedroom
four-bath it's just the two of us right
just the two
again john's singing
you're welcome america and i'm sorry and
we lived in a tiny little apartment too
and it's great you kind of look back on
those days with fond memories they were
miserable but
um we got to figure each other out and
we got to learn one another as the bugs
were coming in the apartment you can
learn all kinds of things
it's good that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books my thanks to
austin and james and will
and the whole crew in there andrew and
of course you john
i guess america's in there too
appreciate you guys listening we'll be
back with you before you know it
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600-plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host joined today
by dr john deloney and we are happy to
take your call this hour triple h we're
here
let's do this five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five
five two two five kayla's kicking us off
in philly's montana kayla welcome to the
ramsay show
hi how are you guys we're so great how
can we help today
good thank you um so
my question is um my husband and i moved
across the country
recently and i am unhappy here um and
i'm just wondering at what point do you
put forth mental health and caring for
that versus finances and putting
yourself in a bind or losing money on
our house
oh
often when you back yourself into a
corner and give yourself one of two
cryptic options
um there's something else going on tell
me what else is going on here
um okay so
oh gosh i don't know i
i'm just very depressed where we live
now um
why are you here what what is it about
this environment this world are you
missing your friends from your old place
your whole community are you not
plugging in did you have a bad
experience what is it
yeah a couple couple of things um we are
very far from our family
um it kind of feels isolating um and the
weather here is a little rougher than i
prefer like winters are very long and
seasonal depression i feel like is a
real thing a super real thing yeah
yeah and so um
it's just hard and
just not as
much to do as or the things that i enjoy
doing
um we had a home before and so i missed
that home in that area and that climate
and
people coming to visit us and we have a
house now but nobody comes to visit
because we're very far away um or if
they do it's very rare so why'd you guys
move stuff like that why'd you move
why um he works he's a truck driver he
works for fedex and if we transferred he
the pay was a lot higher
so he went from being a city driver
in tennessee and then we transferred out
west where he was a road driver and they
get paid quite a bit more
um
so we could always transfer back um but
they aren't hiring at the moment for
road or city so
we're just i'm just here trying to
figure out what to do
how long have you lived there
um we've been here a year but we've been
out west two years okay
um
i had a very similar experience when i
moved from texas where i had my
community my friends and my family and
to
tennessee to nashville into what was a
great job as it was a um a much
it's a much more significant paying job
it was an incredible group of people i
got to work with but i was lonely i was
missing people
and
i
liked doing these things and i wasn't
able to do those things here because now
i'm in the city i've got a reverse of
what you experienced
and ultimately
my wife and i had to sit down and say
okay
we're going to go all in on making this
our home
and it was a completely different
identity shift and she actually went way
faster than i did she went and made
friends got connected started going to
coffee with people and that's not her
nature it's not my nature
and um i had to i've told some stories
on air about inviting people to my house
and be like so this is super weird but
will you be my friend um we go hang out
and when someone would invite me that i
didn't know that well to watch the
fights i said yes every time and i've
come like i'm i'm
my our family goal now a year a few
years after that
time
is this is it
like my my goal and hope in life is to
die in tennessee okay this became my
home but it took some high
intentionality in our part so here's my
challenge to you number one don't frame
this as money or mental health that's
not a fair framing of this
it's not hey you want to be rich and
crazy and depressed that's not really
what's happening here what's happening
here is hey we made a decision together
that we this is going to be a
significant increase in pay for us we're
gonna be able to change some things of
our lives that we thought was gonna be
great and maybe we missed the mark and
that's okay we tried it out two years
three years cool let's get back on the
transfer list and see if when that
happens until then we are not gonna
voluntarily choose misery
i'm not going to choose to be miserable
waiting for this thing that may or may
not happen in two months five months two
years ten years
choose the things that are going to make
you joyful in the meantime that may mean
that we need to add to our budget plane
tickets because we thought we could see
family once a year i want to see them
three and that's just gonna be a thing
that we're gonna do that's a little bit
different um i am not big on going to
coffee with with the gals i'm going to
coffee with the gals i'm gonna make that
a part of my life you see what i'm
saying go all in where you are
and
if you go all in where you are and you
come back and you say hey i want to go
back to tennessee and you end up back
tennessee and kentucky or north carolina
whatever nobody failed anything nobody
lost anything we thought this was going
to be the right thing for us what i
found was
oh man i just missed my family and
friends and that's a completely normal
thing you're supposed to be sad when you
miss your family and friends and now my
new life adventure was finding new
people to do life with and i have you
see what i'm saying
i see yeah i see more of the effort well
it's not no see there you go okay i'm
just not doing enough no no no
not like that
not like that here's what i'm saying
um
it's
it's completely normal to feel you feel
right now
okay
and moving forward you have a choice do
i want to continue this
do i want to continue just to be here
and be sad or do i want to do something
differently not do more don't do
something different
and what you're doing right now is is
you've been
i mean you've been healing right you
made a big major move now we're healing
now we're going to figure out something
that's new and let's set a time limit
with my husband when he's home let's say
let's put a pin on the calendar at six
months let's just check back in with
each other at six months and see how
we're doing and i'm gonna go all in you
go all in we're gonna make this thing
work we're gonna choose to have fun out
here even though i'm not really a hiker
or a i don't fly fish i don't know what
you do in montana um but normally i
wanted to
i'm more of a pedal tavern gal there in
downtown nashville and there's no pedal
taverns out here and i don't know i'm
losing right i'm being
i'm being rude but
um
decide to go all in there and then put
something on the calendar and it gives
you some peace right this isn't a
forever thing and this isn't a cast into
the ocean and if you are struggling
if you are feeling depression in a way
that i don't want to get out of bed i
don't like anybody um the the
i i've just i don't have joy
please call somebody okay
yeah please go visit a counselor okay
and yes seasonal depression is very very
very real
very real um there's all kinds of lights
you can get there's all kinds of
interventions you can do with lighting
around your house and activities you can
do to help with the
lights that is a very real thing um and
winter is coming right so be ready for
that as it heads your way yeah that's
huge yeah when i moved to nashville john
from mobile which i had moved from
boston you just reset and i had to go
all right i'm gonna get plugged into my
local church i made some great friends
there i started here at ramsey solutions
i knew no one and now there's some of my
best friends here to my best community
via the church and work and i love it
and i can't ever imagine going back to
boston but that takes a lot of time and
intentionality and that's all we're
asking for and some awkwardness and some
failure it's a part of it and you're a
king of awkward
john has mastered it i love it more of
the ramsay show coming up
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
balloon our question of the day comes
from blinds.com their 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color they will remake
your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best deal today's question comes
from will in new york will writes my
wife and i earn about 83 000 a year and
have over 238 000 in student loans auto
loans credit cards etc
i did a couple of balance transfers and
split a credit card between a few to get
zero percent interest rates on as much
of the debt as possible
i feel we are somewhat on track doing
the debt snowball while still paying the
minimum on some and trying to get the
ones with zero percent interest paid off
before the intro rate expires
i just turned 30 so i'm trying also
trying to build a small emergency fund
and feeling pressured to start a 401 and
plan for retirement
i don't want to be in debt anymore and i
fantasize about paying cash for a house
but fear that will never happen
any advice or guidance you can offer
would be greatly appreciated um
man it's a tough situation gosh this guy
sounds just like john delooney we've
been there john we're like we're gonna
game the system we're gonna move this to
the zero percent card and do some
balance transfers no it's it's the when
he says i just fantasized but i remember
just just walking around the house when
my wife was asleep at night thinking
like i should be able to like our life
should be different than this like i
remember that feeling and yes i remember
like trying to come up with every scheme
in the book to figure it out like a way
to cut corners and do different and
whatever yeah um yeah so let's address
one thing you're doing too much at once
man yes we gotta slow down and focus on
one thing at a time that is the power of
the baby steps which means we're not
working on the emergency fund right now
we have our starter emergency fund of a
thousand then we're doing the debt
snowball then the emergency fund and
then we'll start investing in the 401k
and you're 30. you still have a lot of
life ahead of you a lot of people john
oh i'm 30 i'm it's too late for me john
and the same person at 20 is feeling
that way and the same person to 40 is
feeling that way it's not too late but
you've got to take intentional steps and
when i see fantasize about paying cash
for a house and then i look at their
situation that's like
me fantasizing about being the best
guitar player in the world but i don't
want to practice guitar ever and it's
just it's part of it like we have to get
out of debt have margin back in our life
to be able to pay cash for a house so
you're right right now it is a fantasy
because you have 238 000 of debt and
you're sitting here playing games
i
this is a conversation that's not talked
about enough um i think and and me and
you we didn't do a better job of talking
about it
um
with this type of student loan debt i
didn't have this much but we had six
figures um
we we got pretty radical we moved
and we i think we we've moved into a
residence hall into a dorm right it may
be that living in one of the most
expensive states in the united states is
just not tenable anymore and we're gonna
take our jobs and we're moving to kansas
we're moving to nebraska we're moving
somewhere where the cost of living is
exponentially less expensive and that
means we're not going to be able to be
in a cool city and that means we're not
going to be able to do some cool
whatevers and this isn't that but this
is how much freedom means to us
um and we're going to pay a little bit
of money to move or we're going to get
new jobs whatever the thing is
we're going to get radical we're going
to get radical and right now 83 000 a
year in new york paying off that much
it's going to be years and years we've
got to double that income yes six months
we got to get different jobs and i know
that you love your job but i know you
feel safe at your job you got to get
different jobs and we're probably
selling the cars that's right we're
selling we got to get radical about and
we're cutting up the credit cards and we
don't care if it's zero percent or 20
we're going to pay it off smallest to
largest because that's going to make us
feel the progress it's going to motivate
us to actually do this thing yeah and
we're pausing that retirement no matter
how much pressure i don't know who's
feeling pressured i don't know where
that pressure's coming from
for me it came it just came from shame
it just came from this picture that this
[ __ ]
should be investing by now i like i'm
gonna i'm failing yeah and that fails
just it just spins and spins and spins
on you and by the way
if you choose to stay in new york we had
a teacher who did that free scream that
was like yeah i was a teacher and the
moment i got off i just went and drove
uber eats
all night and then i got up in the
morning and did uber and then i went and
was a teacher and she did that for a
period of time she paid off a ton of
money right so if you're gonna stay in
new york cool it's going to cost you a
soul tax you're going to have to work
like crazy
but do it man just do it it's worth it
but you got to go all in and that's been
a theme on the show today you can't be
ish because you're going to get ish
results and you're going to be emailing
us and going well i try to do the zero
percent i try to move it over here i'm
trying to invest because i know that's
good and i want to get that emergency
fund and then you wonder why you're not
making any progress here's a good
example i spent some time with the mind
pump guys in san jose awesome guys i'm
really doing for the fitness industry
what dave is doing he has done with the
financial industry right
and um
we're talking about getting getting in
shape and losing weight and building
muscle and what will is doing here is
like you know what i'm going to lose
some weight and i'm going to get in
shape and i'm gonna get stronger and so
he turned the treadmill up as fast as it
would go and he got a barbell and he's
got like a kettlebell and he's running
and trying to lift and throw the
kettlebell at the same time you're gonna
get yourself hurt man this whole thing
stop do these things in the right order
right let's um let's start lifting
weights and let's lose weight and then
let's build muscle over time and then
once we get
more healthy then we can start let's do
this thing in the right order right so
same with will we got a plan for you man
just follow the plan
thanks for the question after it brother
absolutely let's go to the phones lacey
joins us up next in tulsa lacey welcome
to the show
thank you for taking my call how are you
today we're doing great how can we help
good um i am thinking of maybe starting
a side business um my husband and i have
a special needs son
and um
we
have a trust and so i'm wondering
if we should put the money um
from the side business into we do not
have like our three to six month
emergency fund
we're about a thousand dollars or so
away from having our debt paid off and
so i'm wondering should we put the money
into the
emergency fund or put it over in the
trust to
take care of our son you know long long
term what's the nature of special needs
um he has down syndrome and then last
year we also um got an autism diagnosis
so we have down syndrome and autism okay
how old
he's 11. he's 11. is he just a
is he your rambunctious smiley
ball of fun
yes
all of the above very hyper it's so
great i love it i love it i love it i
love it so with this trust are you
planning on releasing this uh as he you
know enters adulthood
um we
have within our trust we have like the
special needs um
set up more we did it more for
when we set it up it was more for just
the
care of you know something should happen
to us and
just recently i've started trying to
think of you know we need funds in there
as well to care for him
um i don't know that it would ever be
released to him directly
probably just depending on how he
you know progresses as you can see
i don't know and what his care situation
looks like
and whether you guys are yeah well the
best thing for him financially is for
you guys to get a hold of your own
finances and so that means following the
baby steps we're putting any extra
income towards the baby steps which
means we're paying off this thousand
dollars with that money we're filling up
three to six months emergency fund with
that money and then baby step four
through seven we go from intense to
intentional and so if you want to at
that point invest 15 of your income
and then put any extra money into the
trust i think that's when the time to do
it and you can also designate
your retirement if you were to pass away
whatever you're putting into retirement
would roll into this trust and the sale
of your home would roll into this trust
right so
it's not like you're going to lose this
down the road you see what i'm saying
yeah our home is not in our trust name
and that's one thing i'm needing to do
um is to you know deed it over into our
trust
um
our
we
sold our home last year and just
purchased this one and so our last home
was in in the name of our trust sure but
i have not gotten this one sent over
yet yeah and that's one of those things
that as a parent um that can just be a
burr in the back of your
i just uh just it just kind of just go
get it done just make a note get it done
this week um knock that out and get that
off your get that off your chest so it's
just your your day will be a little bit
lighter and you're about to knock out
your debt you're on the doorstep of debt
freedom and by the end of the year
you're gonna have that fully funded
emergency fund and it's going to put you
guys in a different place when it comes
to your foundation of money so i'm real
proud of you guys uh way to go love that
little love that little blood 11 year
old that's fantastic thank you so much
for the call this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show and it
is that time of day when we get to
celebrate someone on the debt-free stage
and that person is debbie how are you
debbie how are you doing fantastic
welcome welcome so you paid off some
debt didn't you i did a little bit where
you from uh shakur pennsylvania near
pittsburgh north of pittsburgh okay
awesome how much debt did he pay off i
paid off ninety eight thousand one
hundred seven dollars whoa
how long did that take 38 months
all right and your range of income
during that time uh it started at 65 000
and it ended at 177. whoa okay what do
you do for a living i'm a nurse oh and
is that all nursing is that travel
nursing no
wow
fantastic nurses have had a boring last
three years or so
oh my goodness that's quite the jump so
what was that jump overtime or what
happened
promotions i work at a hospital and then
i picked up at visiting nurses so i
worked all the time i was never home my
kids never saw me i worked doubles uh
all my days off
all the time are a single mom i am yeah
wow you're a rock star you're actually a
a hero in a t-shirt actually without a
cape that's incredible thanks wow okay
so what type of debt was the 98 000
uh it was my car
it was credit cards i had co-signed a
student loan
i charged everything i charged my bed
is everything wow
so what what got you to that point where
you were just charging everything and
going like were you in la la land or did
you feel like well this is what you're
supposed to do well i thought i could
juggle everything i was pretty good at
juggling all my credit cards and then i
bought a house i couldn't afford
and then two weeks after we moved in
murphy moved in and stayed for about six
months and thirty thousand dollars oh i
was totally broken totally
i had uh done financial piece and failed
it before
so then uh my daughter who's here with
me today she said why don't you just try
it again you know you're not you don't
have anything to lose you're already in
the hole
so i said okay so love that
encouragement you're already at rock
bottom it can't get worse mom i can't go
anywhere you get lower so
hand me a shovel and hold my beer i can
get deeper right exactly well done so
you went through it again
i did i credit i cut up all my credit
cards and that day i applied for the
visiting nurse job wow and that was 38
months ago yeah just about yeah that's
incredible so how did you hear about us
in the first place
um i had googled how to pay off debt
because i thought i was going to be
smart and paid off and still juggle my
credit cards which is
ridiculous after you look back you
really can't do that
you have to go all in or you're not
going to make it it's like having a fire
extinguisher in one hand and a
flamethrower in the other example yeah
we put out a fire over here i thought i
could do it but i didn't i failed how
long have you been doing this all by
yourself
uh
how long have i been uh
seven
seven years seven years okay so when i
look at your story
um one word that comes up a lot is a lot
of loss
right a lot like
we lost this and we lost them the we we
got a house and we lost our sanity and
we lost our money and then murphy moved
in
and then i don't want us to forget like
we could ever forget that when you
started this journey 36 three years ago
the world was literally on fire right
and so
what happened like
that's
an extreme testament to your character
and strength that you chose to stand up
in the midst of all that chaos how'd you
do that i
i got really scared with the covid um in
the hospital it's a different world and
you know people outside
we were told when we started kovid that
pack a bag because you may not leave
so i was frightened that i was going to
leave my kids with all that debt and i
thought
i did that myself and i'm going to leave
it to my kids
so from then on they're my why
wow that's how i did it i just i
i i need you to hear me say just
person to person parent to parent what
you've done is amazing well thank you
and yes you've been really open about
some of the knuckleheaded things you've
done with money and whatever
what you have done here is brave and
courageous and inspiring and you
sacrificed a couple of years of being
around
your kids
to change their life forever and it
changed your life forever and i just
need you to know just person to person
i'm this is inspiring and it's amazing
thank you proud of you it's awesome
so inspire someone else out there who's
got a hundred thousand dollars of debt
what do you say the key to getting out
of debt is um you have to have a big
enough why
or you're just not going to do it it's
just so hard
it is not for the faint of heart
it was so hard i cried a lot going to
work i called my daughter she's a nurse
as well and uh she heard a lot from me
but she just keep keep going keep going
you'll get there so was she your biggest
cheerleader yeah all my kids helped out
they took care of the home so i didn't
have to i didn't cook i didn't get
groceries i did nothing because they
took care of everything well you you
raised some great kids who are
self-sustaining that's a big part of it
self-sustaining yeah is that a word no
but okay it's cool though i thought i
could google that it's a word very
self-stink wow
that's pretty incredible
so
and i'm older so it's like could i do it
because i was 52 when i started and i'm
like wow i see i watch all the debt-free
screams and they're like oh these are
young couples and here i am an older
mother
but you know so it was a personal
challenge to yourself going oh yeah is
it too late for me no it's not so is
that what you'd say to someone else
who's in their 40s or 50s their 60s
right it's not too late nope yeah the
real question you have to ask yourself
when you're 52 is i'm going to be 55
either way do i want to be debt-free or
do i want to have debt that's the
question right
are you still working this this second
job have you let it go and no i still
work it but i work it because i want to
not because i have to that's different
yep
that's incredible so how does it feel oh
it feels great it looks great you seem
light airy
you could just float away at any moment
i'm very excited
have you have you had some of these
moments where the checks cash and you
have no bills yeah oh yeah i paid it off
in uh
what was it february march okay march
3rd yeah
fantastic we're so proud of you we've
got some parting gifts for you we've got
uh baby steps millionaires dave's number
one best-selling book that's the next
chapter in your story as you've changed
your family tree and step into baby
steps millionaire status and of course a
copy of financial peace university the
newest edition you can gift that to
maybe one of your nurse friends who's
going you did what now in 30 how yeah
show me the way you can hand that to
them as well as a copy of the total
money makeover to kickstart someone
else's journey
so proud you brought the kids with you
um i brought my older daughter allison
and my young son emerson and this is my
son-in-law i love it well you want to
bring them up on stage are they
screaming with you i i don't think okay
they're hanging out they're like are you
screaming i didn't know that i wanted to
be a part of this hey you all had to
take care of the house you need to get
up there and scream with it you guys
were a part of this i have to add my
son-in-law is awesome anything time
anything would break he's like no you're
not paying for it he was over before i
even put the phone down so wow kudos to
him
incredible people in your corner i do
that's awesome well let's let's get to
it the moment we've all been waiting for
it's debbie and allison in emerson
pittsburgh pennsylvania 98
107 paid off in 38 months making 65 all
the way to 177 count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream three two one
i'm debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the opposite of a debbie downer
john right there
that's my dad joke for the day
no thanks tom hanks
thank you for using my line again that
is fantastic i love these stories john
it really is inspiring never gets old
and i just love the fact that you can
decide at any age and i love what you
said you're going to be 55 anyways
do you want to be debt-free at 55 or do
you want to keep living how you've been
living yeah
my wife had a few friends they were 35
and they were all hanging out talking
and they said man we always wish we'd
gone to med school so dumb we should go
to med school but now it's too old and
it would be seven years of
going to school and going through
rotation and my wife because she's very
very wise she said that's not that's not
what you should be asking yourself what
you should be asking yourself is you're
going to be 42 either way do you want to
be a doctor when you're 42 or not a
doctor 42 and they were like oh well
played right and your mom has an
inspiring story of that too yeah it's
very similar i i um i just have people
in my life my mom my dad people who have
made some major changes
past ages when people think you can
change right and debbie's the perfect as
if there's a certain day where it's like
all right it's too late this is it
you're always gonna have back pain
you're always just good you know what
couple y'all been married so you're
always just gonna argue it's just gonna
be that way you know what single mom you
just just you can't do it you're always
gonna struggle with me i can't do it um
hey you're already working a full-time
job now don't work too hard um you have
to do this with the kids you got to do
debbie's one of those curve busters man
that just says yeah i'm gonna find all
the rules out the window i'm gonna get
this thing done for 38 months she said
i'm gonna pay a price for a time but
then the next 30 years of her life
freedom baby that's what it's all about
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day matthew 5 3
you're blessed when you're at the end of
your rope
with less of you there is more of god in
his rule
franklin roosevelt said when you reach
the end of your rope tie a knot in it
and hang on
good stuff there hey george it's no
secret that i love a good concert if
it's gonna be a good one i'm gonna be
there and i know folks listening have
something in mind that you would like to
do with some extra cash like go to a
concert go have some fun go on a date go
do something cool so i'm super excited
to announce that it is back
we are giving away 500 bucks every week
in a grand prize of 3 000 in august in
our ramsey cash giveaway that's big john
you know on top of national make a will
month it's also giveaway month could
this month get any better
no but seriously think about all the
cool things you could do with that extra
cash you could fill up your gas tank at
least twice all the way up without even
worrying about what gas station is the
cheapest that is true luxury
all the groceries you can buy without
feeling like you just got robbed you can
add it to your investments pay off debt
you name it or if you're like dr john
you can go to that concert you've been
waiting to see which john goes to a
concert about once a week and uh without
me and if you were like george you can
get the pedicure you could go get two a
month instead of just one no i get them
for my dogs john they're not for me
anymore that is right sacrifice but you
can go enter the giveaway ramsay
solutions.com giveaway and you can do
this every single day in august for
extra chances to win no purchase
necessary but you got to be 18 or older
sorry kids ramsay solutions.com
giveaway
all right let's go to the phones thomas
joins us up next in greensboro north
carolina thomas welcome to the show
hey y'all thanks so much for having me
sure how can we help
so i have one primary question and then
the second one if we have time for it
but to give you some context and
background to the first one
so
my fiancee and i are wondering if we're
about to spend a little bit too much on
a honeymoon or not so she is projected
to make about 28 i'd say about 32 000
this year she is a beautician she does
hair cutting
then i will make probably about a little
bit more than 45 this year i drive a
straight truck for a living i plan on
getting my cdl probably the next two to
four months so that will also increase
my uh income she has absolutely no debt
whatsoever and she has about i think
three or four months of emergency fund
i have a thousand dollars in an
emergency fund
i do have a little debt i have one
credit card with about 1500 bucks on it
that will be paid off by the
wedding our wedding will be in october
we're thinking about eight thousand
dollars for the wedding five of that is
coming generously from our parents and
they were cash flowing the rest
but then there's the honeymoon we
were kind of wanting to take a little
bit longer of a honeymoon i i personally
haven't had a week over a week vacation
in about five years so we were thinking
about two weeks
and the grand total was probably about a
little over 13 000. so we'd be going
we'd be going into it a little where are
you guys going
to the moon this is like an overwater
bungalow in fiji
i wish uh so we will be going about if
if we can
afford it we would be going to
st thomas and the virgin islands for
about a week then we'd be coming back
home going to our state fair north
carolina for about two days and then
going to the biltmore resort in
asheville for about three days so that
would all be paid for in cash as well
we'd be cash flowing that so that was
kind of my question we've been making
about 75 000 a year when we're married
together but we didn't we were just
trying to figure out you know even
though we were debt-free even though we
would have some a decent income if if
maybe we should back off a little bit
yeah i mean i don't know if i'm a
cheapskate but spending 13k in your
honeymoon an 8k on the wedding feels
backwards to me that's pretty wild it
does feel a little sideways that's like
the guy that buys the 2000 car and puts
5 000 rims and tires on it just seems a
little bit backwards gotcha so i mean i
don't know what you spent on your
honeymoon john that not near that
the purpose of the honeymoon
you're going somewhere tropical there's
not that much difference between cancun
and and st thomas as far as you know a
nice view
so if i'm you i'm gonna do some heavy
research to go how can we cut this thing
down to three four thousand dollars and
still have an amazing time
yeah and yeah and
yes if you don't mind we we have done a
tad bit of research we did get a um
a person to look over things for us it
it's really things like the flights that
are just killing us so again we've only
put the deposit on some of these things
so we can take it back
and uh from what you're telling us we
may end up doing that so i that we can
get all your money back i believe so
we've only put like three or four
hundred dollars on the deposit and
they're countable two weeks up until the
arrival so okay so look as as a guy
who's been married for a long time we i
just went to asheville for my 20th
anniversary so it's great place you put
you're picking well it's awesome
um
there is going to be some stress to
dealing with the wedding to getting
married to moving into a place together
even though we got all planned out we've
been dating a while we're best friends
we love each other all those things it's
just going to be a season of stress
and if you throw thirteen thousand
dollars go into this country then get
home and then go in here you're gonna
end this two weeks more tired than you
started
and then you're to launch back into work
she's going to be back right so you're
you're setting yourself up
um to stumble at the at the starting
line
i would much rather used to take a much
smaller a
less expensive not cheaper but a less
expensive
time for you all to just be together and
rest and enjoy life have some fun do
some cool rest doesn't mean do nothing
right but but rest means we're gonna do
some stuff that's gonna be cool and then
let's put a pin in it let's say our five
year anniversary or a three year
anniversary or our completely debt-free
anniversary we're going to st thomas for
two weeks and we're gonna blow it out
dude do that right and then that's gonna
be something i'll work forward to y'all
work for together and it's not gonna be
stressful on top of stress on top of
stress yeah i'm probably gonna punt at
the asheville trip the biltmore trip to
the spring and just focus on this
tropical trip maybe do a week maybe
eight or nine days and uh check out
costco travel that's where i've
personally booked my honeymoon we just
did a three-year anniversary trip to
cabo we did it all through costco travel
and it was a fraction of what you just
described and it was all inclusive we
had a great time it was very relaxing
you never heard of costco sean is
writing down i'm writing it down let's
go travel yeah i'm telling you dude you
can get some great deals it'll include
flights there's a lot of great options
there so i got peanut butter and uh dog
food i didn't know you could get a
costco trap trip to mexico today we've
got like virtual travel agents that will
help i was just like hey here's my
budget what's the three best places to
go they told me i said what's the three
best resorts on each of those great you
just saved me 14 hours of research
and i just booked it i'm in so that's
what i would encourage you to do thomas
congratulations on the wedding that's
fantastic uh but 13 grand goodness
gracious that's some that's some bougie
lifestyle right there to go back to the
fair and eat fried oreos
all right lynn joins us up next in
charlotte lynne get right to the
question we're up against the clock
okey dokey thanks for having me i am
getting conflicting advice if this is
the right time to make a move sell my
house
and escape from the super congested
suburbs of charlotte north carolina and
buy another house in western north
carolina in a rural environment okay so
why wouldn't you do it
uh my loved ones are saying this is not
the right time to move people don't move
in a recession uh people move all the
time
okay yeah all the time
all the time
here you have a question
are you going to go forward spot
financially to move
i i
yes
yes
do you have a pile of debt or do you
have money in the bank
nope i could tell you you're good lynn's
crushing it yep yep i have about two
two hundred thousand uh for
retirement i have 4100 emergency uh 1800
credit card debt
and i do all on my jeep wrangler
busted
well moving is going to be it's going to
have a cost to it where are you going to
downsize
i
probably will do a lateral move i bought
this house for 236. a realtor i met with
last week said i could sell it before 15
and i'd like to
put it all into the next home so lateral
move okay well if you do it here's what
i would do lynn i would pay off all of
my debt as part of this and then maybe
downsize slightly so that i'm not in a
crunch financially right and get an
emergency pay off all your debts get an
emergency fund so when you buy this new
house out there um it's a peaceful
transaction and if that's pausing on the
move until we're out of debt with the
emergency fund that's a great plan too
there's not a ton of urgency around this
so that's what john and i would do yeah
teaches i got no problem moving right
now
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books my thanks to my co-host dr
john delony all the folks in the booth
and you america we appreciate you
listening until next time spend wisely
save intentionally and give generously
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you